[Music]
hi everybody my name is yuri i'm a cloud
customer and Janee are based here in San
Francisco focused on Google cloud
reliability hello everyone my name is
Anthony Bhushan and I'm a customer
engineers specialist focused on
kubernetes awesome all right so let's
get into it so this is us so the first
thing and I'm sure that if you've been
in this lounge all day or if you've seen
any other presentations you've probably
seen this any number of times but since
we're going to be talking about putting
site reliability engineering your sree
principles into practice the first thing
we should talk about is what is that
reliability engineering and what are the
principles yeah probably a good place to
start
yeah all right so and this is maybe your
background but I think sort of the
purpose of sree to solve some of the
tensions that arise in a product
development lifecycle so can you tell me
like how does a job play into it first
yeah I mean I think this is something
where you know a lot of the digital
transformation probably within the past
decade has been focused around agile and
I think a co-worker for me something
that best where scrum is to agile as
we've sre is to DevOps right and so
agile was largely focused on kind of
breaking down barriers between product
management product development and
actual software engineering and
developers right but on the other side
of the coin and this is where it becomes
relevant for sres is how do we build
reliable services and a lot of folks
stand by
that requires breaking down similar
walls between developers and operations
IT operations exactly so that's what
DevOps is intend to do right DevOps is
intended to bring development operations
together give them a common InnoCentive
model stop them from fighting right
eliminate that wall of confusion yeah
where you throw code over the wall and
hope it works out right and ultimately
just to get to market faster yeah
exactly as both of these types of
practices yep absolutely
all right so sre or site reliability
engineering is essentially a specific
implementation or a specific set of
practices that we here at Google have
found that really enable this right and
there are five key areas right so it's
about reducing organization
organizational silos operating with
failure as a normal outcome implementing
changes gradually in an automated way
and finally making all decisions
data-driven driven and measuring
everything so at a high level that's
what s our review all right now what are
the principles upside reliability
engineering right if you've read this or
we book and I see we have at least one
copy of it on the back shelf I think
there may be there more I don't know if
those are for grabbing or not but maybe
we'll just say no they're not all right
don't grab that copy it's only for
display set design yeah so the the SRV
principles that we'll focus on for this
specific talk our first service levels
and air budgets and if you saw the
previous talk some of that should be
familiar to you and we'll talk about
observability and finally we'll get into
release engineering all right so let's
start by talking about service levels
and they are budgets so this is a famous
kind of famous line that in some ways I
think underpins a lot of what SRP is all
about and that is that 100 percent is
the wrong reliability target for
everything yeah we have a couple posters
but I am curious to hear so what can you
explain a little bit about the
methodology or the understanding behind
that yeah like why isn't it a good
target for a liability yeah good
question at a very fundamental level
because there's no point to delivering a
service that's 100% reliable because
your users will
our experience or hard percent
reliability the methods that they use to
connect and consume your service are not
a hundred percent reliable and they
never will be right
you've all got bones you all use mobile
networks you all use the Wi-Fi at the
conference none of that stuff is on a
percent reliable right so what is the
point of running a service 100 percent
reliable
that users will never benefit from right
the second thing is the only way you
actually achieve a hundred percent
reliability is to eliminate all changes
right change is risk risk means failure
means downtime so the only way you
prevent any downtime or any performance
issues is by removing all change which
means you can never do anything you can
never build anything you never advance
the service in any meaningful way right
so that's why a hundred percent is the
wrong target so then if the hundred
percent is the wrong target right what
is the right target what is the service
level objective that you service to
deliver on and conversely what do you do
with that gap between a hundred percent
and your actual s alone right and then
that's the error budget and the big
things I think is often lost in this
conversation of SLO and error budget is
the idea that error budgets actually
allow you to increase velocity right
service level objectives and it strictly
adhering to them is not just a way to
prevent developers from doing stuff if
at the end of the month or at the end of
that fellow window whatever it may be
yeah you still have air budget available
that's actually an opportunity for your
developers to do more stuff it's wrong
to experiment it they can experiment
with the code experiment with flags and
features experiment with the
infrastructure and config management
right all of that is enabled by having
development and
operations or site reliability
engineering align on a common principle
of operating from an air budget so then
the next obvious question is all right
that all sounds good we all agree SLO is
our the way to go but we heard they talk
about putting them into practice
especially with bag driver right so how
do we do this well what we want to do is
to actually a load you know configure
monitoring for SLO is in stackdriver
so that we can actually measure and make
sure that we are in fact delivering on
the promises that we make to to our
users in the service life level
objective or the SLO and then we want to
alert on both SLO violations but also
increases an air budget burn rate that
let us know when an allergen SLO
violation might actually be appended so
what is that going to look like good
stop
slide that for a second and here we're
gonna get into some of the new stuff
those actually announced basically
earlier today you saw the keynote you
saw anthos as one of the announcements
one of the key components is the cloud
service measure or the antis service
measure what this is gonna allow us to
do it's actually exposed all of the
services that are now running in our
project for any given service for
example this product page service I can
get details for it let's see how good
speaking of reliable Wi-Fi so that's not
bad we can go - well there you go we are
having a reliability issue with our
service reliability monitoring we can
get into the service we can understand
what's actually going on that we can set
s loz and from there we can actually set
alerting policies on SLO violations that
will take us into stackdriver
so now we have the ability to monitor
service health directly within the cloud
console we have the ability to set s loz
against those services and actually
configure alerting and notifications on
not just metric threshold is the way
that alerting policies have enabled us
to do for years at this point but actual
SLO violations right so that's really
kind of the first s re principle that we
want to cover which is all about
operating off SLO s not just metric
thresholds and then configure our
learning for those inspectors and
ultimately this brings us closer to a
user first mindset right because
ultimately the user isn't seeing
directly CP utilization but they are
certainly seeing whatever you are
defining as your service level of
judging
exactly all right so let's watch our
second principle which is all about
observability right so what is
observability well it's just monitoring
repackaged right uh-huh I'm quoting
someone here who is a lot smarter than I
am and knows a lot more about this Cyndi
literally wrote the book on monitoring
distributed systems if you haven't read
it you should it's really good
she's like I said knows that stuff a lot
more than either one of us do but
essentially observability is the
combination of we often refer to as the
golden signals right metrics logs and
traces so a logical question might be
all right well why do we need all that
what does all of that do well let's
start by talking about metrics right
metrics are a way to really understand
the health of our system and the health
of the components in our system over
time right because they represent the
movement of specific values again
against a time scale and if the question
is all right like there are there are
lots of metrics what should we really
pay attention to fundamentally they're
really three right traffic how much
stuff is happening wait and see how fast
stuff is happening and errors is are our
users actually able
do what they need to do you can add
saturation to that which is really just
a way to understand basically our
ability to deliver against our capacity
that's great because that's the first
place you can look at to understand
whether or not issues of your service
have to do with running out of capacity
but fundamentally that's really what you
need in order to understand the health
of your system so how do you get metrics
in stackdriver right what do they come
from
well if you're running on in GCP if your
easy manage GCP resources and all that
stuff is an instrument for you right out
of the box so you go to stack drive you
go to the resources section there's an
entire GCP area that shows you the
metrics for all the various GCP managed
services right so for example something
like pub/sub there's a it builds your
dashboard out of the box you can see
metric you can see information all right
in there allows you create an alerting
policy if you need it again some
resources you can obviously filter the
information by specific resource if you
want to filter down to specific pop
subtopic the other thing you should be
aware of is this idea of transparent
slis this is a relatively new addition
to stack driver but it actually allows
you to include SLI signals from the
platform in your own reporting and
alerting even if you so choose so
transparent US allies give you latency
and error rate and traffic data or
Google platform api's so if you want to
see like what the latency is of the
compute API within your within your
project or any of the other API is that
you actually relying on you can now
include these signals in your own
dashboards
correlate them with signals that are
being emitted from your own applications
or services and really quickly
understand whether a problem that's
you're observing has to do with your
code or something on our side and so
this might be really useful in scenarios
where we're adopting immutable
infrastructure blowing out new changes
it is dependent upon some of these
platform API is right we want to look at
that any kind of
juncture there environment exactly yeah
very much so if you're running computer
infrastructure in DCP specifically
Google compute engine instances metrics
from those are created automatically
when you first just spin up the
instances you get basic metrics like CPU
disk i/o and network throughput just
again out of the box automatically you
also have the option of installing your
mark on the stack driver monitoring
agent on those instances to both capture
additional information like memory for
example lots of additional metrics also
get created when you install the agent
and finally you get process level
monitoring so you can actually see
whether or not a particular process on
your instance is running how much
resources it's consuming and then you
can create you know alerting and things
like that against that process as well
if you so choose so some there's a lot
of value to using the monitoring agent
and finally just to kind of quick dive
into custom metrics right let's say that
you want to emit specific information
from within your application you have a
few options there your first option is
to actually use the stack driver
monitoring API directly the big
advantage of doing that is it gives you
full control you control exactly against
which resources the metrics are written
against you know how often they're
written right what the labels are all
that sort of thing you know the big
trade-off obviously is complexity right
you have to manage all of that stuff
your second option is to use open census
which is a library that does both
distributed tracing and the metric
instrumentation for a subset of
languages that it supports and that's
the big advantage right you can actually
use a single library to boot to do both
tracing and metric instrumentation you
know the big sort of trade-off there is
that the language support is a little
bit uneven not every language that opens
has to support supports today will
actually do both traces and metrics you
kind of have to look at like where what
are you writing your application and
what can you do and then the last option
is Prometheus so this is an open source
monitoring tool lots of you may be
familiar with it I saw someone here
earlier with a Prometheus shirt on you
it gives you additional visibility into
the infrastructure that Prometheus
it basically instrumentation is running
on the big trade-off there is that if
you want prometheus metrics to show up
in stackdriver
the only way that works today is if you
have Prometheus running in kubernetes so
if you install it on the gke cluster and
then patch that deployment with a
stacked armoured collector you can
ingest those metrics in the stack drive
so the last part about prometheus is
that it allows you to ingest you can you
can ingest Prometheus metrics in the
stack driver but the only way you can do
that is if Prometheus is running in in
kubernetes because you can patch that
Prometheus deployment with a stack
driver collector and in just those
metrics in the stacks right right so the
second kind of signals we talk about is
logs right so logs are very much events
right what happened at a specific point
in time right they can be structured
they can be very unstructured as we've
learned when we are trying to build some
demos right sometimes you get a law
against is just like one massive line of
text then you don't know what to do with
it
so there's lots of places where they
come from there's lots of data to store
there are a few different ways to get
logs into stackdriver logging obviously
all of the GCP services emit logs
natively there's nothing you need to do
there there's no setup at all for your
services we have client libraries for
stackdriver logging that you can use to
again send logs to stackdriver and then
as you're running on kubernetes you can
use pull indeed to basically just have
your containers write logs to stand it
out or standard error and then fluent
deal we'll just in just those logs
instead of this tag driver back again
and finally traces right so traces are
all about latency especially
understanding service to service
communication latency in distributed
systems right so this is highly
structured data right that are made up
of spans and child spans one trace is
scoped to a specific request and a few
examples of how you use tracing to get
this data into stackdriver so the first
option is you can use the trace agent so
this is something you live with just
including your code you put it in as a
very
sort of top of the file and it'll trace
all requests in and out of that
particular service the big advantage of
using the stack Drive a trace agent is
that it's really easy like literally one
line of code the big trade-off of using
it is that it doesn't give you any
control right so you can't actually
manually create spans or you can't
manually create traces of spans right
it'll just do tracing for you your
second option is again open census so we
talked about that at beginning usually
you know a lot more control I mean the
big trade-off there is complexity and
then your third option is open tracing
which is another open source tracing
library you know the trade-off of open
tracing is that only that's tracing it
does not do both tracing and metrics the
way that open census does however yes so
how do people I mean it seems like
there's a couple distinct libraries yeah
consensus open tracing Hydra folks
actually navigate that space yeah that's
a great question and the good news is
there is that we're not we these two
projects are actually merging so there's
the links of the medium post that you
can see in the deck here and you can
find this on medium pretty easily but
open tracing and open census arts are
gonna merge so there will really be just
a single open source tracing library
that you'll be able to use I don't think
this is gonna happen like tomorrow but
this is very much the direction of these
two projects and again and I say this as
a sort of an outside observer I'm not
myself a member of either these projects
all right
so to kind of wrap up this particular
section right the observability or the
ability to understand what is happening
in your system it's really the
combination of three major signals right
metrics logs and traces stackdriver
gives you a common back-end to collect
all that information we've talked about
some of the options that you can use to
do so now and yeah you should do that
it's gives you much good information
that you can use during incident to the
trouble chair I think just saying
totally from my perspective some of the
exciting stuff about stackdriver
specifically is seeing folks kind of
come in
standardizing on Prometheus I'm being
able to see that there is that
integration yeah but there's also on the
flip side a lot of native integration
just into those GCP resources almost an
oauth2 setup right so all right so now
let's talk about a third principle which
is release engineering all right so I'm
going to use this switch should look the
same it work it is all right cool so you
know the last SRT principle that we're
going to cover today is release
engineering and so I just want to get a
quick show of hands for folks when they
think about release engineering the
stack driver comes to mind or monitoring
in general come to mind as a as a
forefront principle or a piece of
release engineering show hands
understand I'm now putting my hand up
for that one okay so looks like we got
about four or five people so it looks
like I have some people to win over as
far as convincing you all that
stackdriver does fit you know play a
very integral role with release in
journey release engineering and
specifically release engineering in the
way that the sre kind of book defines it
as all right so let's dive right into it
so there's an actual quote so chapter 8
for those of you who haven't had a
chance to comb through the SRT book
chapter covers release engineering as a
whole right and so I think this ties
back to the initial kind of discussion
point that we had in that first second
or third slide talking about how if we
want services to be more reliable it
requires to invest up front in reliable
and in my opinion standardized release
processes right it's essential that when
we define these upfront that developers
sres and release engineers actually work
together right so talking about breaking
down those boundaries often time is
investing upfront in kind of deciding
what that process looks like and so a
lot of that is been kind of looped into
a lot of the buzzwords of continuous
delivery continuous you know see ICD
right I think Jay Paul read one of the
DevOps days I think in Atlanta really
had my favorite definition of
genius delivery and that's getting your
entire organization to care about
release engineering and and I think
quality assurance and he goes on to say
in a way hate that it had never cared
about them before and so what we're
gonna see here is we're gonna talk about
what release engineering actually means
in the context of sre and then we're
going to talk about how quality
assurance and snack drive are all kind
of fit into this picture right so in
Chapter eight
Kunie these four principles by heart
okay so we're gonna talk about what the
SRA book kind of defines release
engineering as an and it's really
reliant upon four key pillars and that's
self service model and I've tried to sum
them up in kind of single word summaries
so that's being able to provide
automation to your teams right so as we
you know break out into this
microservices world into this to pizza
team world
each of these without the investment in
release engineering upfront resultant
bespoke processes that often especially
I see if folks as they starts to
transition into kubernetes people fall
into the local optimum trap everyone is
writing their own little automation bash
scripts will have you I'm guilty too for
all my demos I don't use this I don't
always use the tools that I'm showing up
here sometimes I'll just write bash but
ultimately we want to create a
self-service model for folks and for
teams to be able to adopt right and so
we you know I think there's a lot of
that in the higher-level sre principles
of just automating a weight toil right I
won't touch too much on high velocity
and hermetic builds but I think a lot of
this is being able to tie this the
immutable infrastructure and docker
right folks expecting to if I have a
docker file and I have a repository this
build should behave the same way no
matter where I'm running it from and
also just being able to rather than
doing hot fixes and SSH into the Machine
and just trying to figure out what's
going on and making those changes being
able to just tear away infrastructure
and deploy a brand new resource and
really treating our infrastructure is
immutable really tiny entities middle to
high velocity and hermetic builds
pillars but the last thing I'm going to
talk about is the enforcement of
policies and procedures and so the way I
see this is that a lot of folks
and you know a lot of us get excited
about technology first and we get
excited about tools first but when it
comes to the pillars of release
engineering oftentimes we want to
reflect our own business processes that
we or compliance processes that we're
completely you know held accountable for
and the you know policies that are
specific to our culture to the way that
our team actually does things and so I
kind of sum that up as configurability
so that the two pillars of release
engineering that I'm going to focus in
on is automation and configurability now
so for folks who kind of take these
words as face value it kind of seems
like they don't have a whole bunch in
common right I think the sre book talks
about automating away releases to the
point where engineers are only needed if
there are issues but that seems a little
bit different from you know folks
adopting configurability to match
whether it's you know shipping off to
specific business units to perform a
kind of intense tests or functional
tests or you know being able to
basically introduce these break points
where automation is not possible right
so human approval processing finding a
sweet spot between the two is often very
difficult so we're gonna try and do that
in the next five minutes so - to solve
that requires an OP centric CI CV kind
of approach so what I mean here is and
so here's just another warning if
everyone's every team is figuring out
their own deployment processes you want
to avoid that local optimum trap and we
really want to design for an OP centric
continuous delivery pipeline right so
this is the ability to have a single
pane of glass to see how all of your
deployments for different services are
progressing and being able to have that
basic kind of audit of what has been
deployed with integrated monitoring and
so this does require a bit more
management effort compared to some of
the other kind of
methods they're outlined on this slide
but it really is worth it to achieve
that balance between configurability and
automation
so let's actually take a look at what
that means and the context that we're
setting for this today is utilizing a
tool called spinnaker can I guess show
of hands of who knows spinnaker okay
most of the room all right no we're
waiting into familiar territory so and
we'll also be talking about how this
fits together within wood stackdriver
right so stackdriver I think needs no
introduction we've covered it in depth
you know provides a holistic solution
across logging and monitoring and
spinnaker is an open source continuous
delivery tool again really focused on
what happens once you have an artifact
and how can we have cloud native api's
to roll out things to VMs or to or to
kubernetes itself so spinnaker is an
open source project I think it's was
initially you know got its Fame at
Netflix but Google has contributed to
the project as well so spinnaker if
you're not familiar with the basic
building blocks I'm just gonna quickly
touch on them that we have the notion of
pipeline stages and tasks right so these
are things that can define you'll see
here in the sample pipeline that we are
triggered off of a new image or vert new
version of an image being pushed to some
type of registry I think in if you're to
do this within Google you might set up a
pubsub trigger once something is pushed
out to Google container registry and
then from there we may have multiple
different stages that define let's say a
Canaria deployment or something like
that right so this pipeline is just a
sequence of actions so let's start with
the common pattern here that I think
I've seen a lot of customers that that
do experiment with spinnaker kind of
take on and this is um manual judgments
so this is the ability within our
pipelines to actually define a human
approval step where this might be
something where QA is monitoring for in
minutes or in hours and they're looking
at a dashboard and trying to define you
know decide whether or not a pipeline
should move forward right so I think an
example is a folks you know looking at
observability across a canary deployment
right but I think and I believe
this is a quote from some from someone
from Netflix who blogged about manual
judgments and they talked about
oftentimes it is just a poor developer
staring at a whole bunch of graphs in a
dashboard that's or Corman combing
through structured or unstructured logs
and trying to figure out whether they
should move forward or roll back right
and so the challenge with this is not
only do developers sometimes find this
boring some developers not all but this
is also challenging at scale right if we
were deploying more frequently and we
are introducing more micro services into
our environment how are we actually you
know what it what becomes the bottleneck
does release engineering become the
bottleneck because every human must you
know every pipeline requires someone to
watch a dashboard for an hour at scale
it becomes challenging if you are doing
this again and I'll talk about you know
how we would automate this away I do
want to show quickly that folks still do
this and and I think for folks getting
started with pipelines there's
absolutely nothing wrong with it so to
define kind of what I was discussing in
that slide you'll see here that I have
an actual spinnaker pipeline and what
we're looking at is this manual approval
stage that I have here so one of the
things that's really useful even if
you're not able to introduce automation
yet or you're not running into that
scale issue yet what you can do is begin
to kind of seed stackdriver into this
manual approval process or your release
engineering so what we were able to do
oh actually I already have that open so
let's just take a look at it what we're
actually able to do is within metrics
Explorer in stackdriver monitoring we
can look at our metrics here and
actually create filters or groups
specific metrics and actually create a
dashboard with that so a fairly easy win
if you're utilizing spinnaker is to be
able to create custom charts that you
want folks to be able to look at from
relevant metrics to help them make that
decision if they should approve a
pipeline to move forward or not so what
you'll see here is that I actually have
this filter defined for 500 response
codes and we see how if I deploy
baseline in the canary together what
that actually looks like as far as the
new version with new
and baseline which is deployed at the
same time as canary to mimic production
and and I don't want to gloss over that
but we can't spend too much time the
note is that it is helpful to deploy
deploy a baseline if you are taking on
canary deployments so that you can have
a fair comparison for the new version of
your application or your canary to
production and the reason that that's
important is because the production
environment that's already been deployed
may already you know they may have
already filled a cache from the database
and this is something that a baseline
would have to do from scratch much like
a canary
right so the first thing you're doing
before you even introduce really any
automation is that you're basically
making a standard that you're making
that decision of whether to move forward
or all back standardized you're saying
instead of like making it a subjective
decision like look at this dashboard
compare the thing if it looks good move
forward if now look back precisely I
think that like spinnaker frames it in
that way to provide instructions on this
manual judgment and because we can embed
a very simple link here that we can
create from this metrics Explorer chart
it's really useful to provide context as
far as what should be observed for a
specific service or application that's
being deployed so that being said if we
can introduce automation we want to
write so spinnaker and stackdriver as a
combination allows for this as well so
you're looking at is an actual I should
have noted that the canary and baseline
that I was presenting is the point into
kubernetes environment and so you'll see
here this is sort of what I was looking
at within that dashboard we have a
baseline we have a canary and both of
these are actually exporting Prometheus
metrics into stackdriver
and and then we are led to a place
called canary analysis and cayenne say
in the diagram and so what are these so
one thing you should know about
spinnaker is that it is based a
microservice based platform so kai anta
is one of these services that is part of
spinnaker that provides automated canary
analysis and so what this means is that
if we have metrics we can actually begin
to create automation where we define
based on these metrics based on what
we're looking at for a non production
environment
can we get a score and based on that
score should that pipeline automatically
move forward right so this is where CAI
Anza and stackdriver come into play
again Chi anta is used to automate this
canary judgment and you can introduce
this as a stage in your spinnaker
pipeline it doesn't involve a human
operator to judge the releases we are
distinctly taking this from the metrics
that we are collecting within
stackdriver
you know so in the example today we're
looking at the request metric from
Prometheus so if you are using or
standardizing on a set of metrics you
can get them into stackdriver
you can build them into this automated
canary analysis within your pipeline
the last thing I'll note is that you can
group together metrics and weight
specific metrics if there's several
metrics that we need to look at in my
example we have a very simple a simple
example but there is I want to note
there's the ability to introduce
complexity much like I'm sure you'll
find in your services as well and I
should point out right kind of referring
back to our first principle tom is loz
with SLO monitoring those actually
become available as metrics in
stackdriver snack can actually have you
can have can to use your SLO metrics and
not just things like error rates you can
actually see like what is my error rate
over you know a 30-minute rolling window
to be able to make those judgments
pretty quickly and make those judgments
off the same judgment to use you that
you use to determine whether or not your
actual service is helping so what I'm
showing you here is we have that very
same pipeline except now we actually
have a stage for a canary analysis where
there was once manual judgment and so
what we see here is if we actually look
at what is configured within this canary
analysis stage that we actually are
configuring metrics here and so you'll
see here that I only have one group says
Group 1 but we can actually create
multiple groups of metrics and then
assign each of those a score as far as
how those should be weighted in this
canary analysis stage so you'll see here
that again I'm going off of the actual
error code here which is 500 if we see
an increase in that we should
the pipeline to fail and so what is
really good about that is that we can
now again for you know pipelines
spinnaker pipelines that don't kind of I
guess yield any distinct or useful or
new information about your about your
application or your service we now no
longer have to insert a human there -
let's say monitor dashboard for 30
minutes or for an hour to come back to
it and then even from there to make a
decision that isn't necessarily
standardized now we can provide
automation where needed so that if we do
have a set of metrics where we can
define this threshold we can introduce
this using spinnaker Kayenta and
stackdriver so the last thing i want to
note is that you know even if you're not
whether or not you're able to automate
this process i think is an open question
for a lot of folks some again and a lot
of it will have to match sort of what
approval processes you require today but
regardless of whether those there's
manual approval or automation one thing
I think folks can adopt and get a quick
win as far as spinnaker and stackdriver
is actually monitoring with context and
I what I mean by that is actually being
able to utilize the notion of a counter
for spinnaker deployments or events from
spinnaker and overlay that on the
performance of your application and so
the way that we actually have this an
example here and actually let me talk to
you first and we'll look at the demo
Orca is again as I mentioned spinnaker
is a set of might is based on a set of
micro services so Orca is the workflow
engine and Orca actually emits events to
echo so what we can actually do is
configure echo to basically we can
provide an external URL to actually get
these events so this might be a
spinnaker pipeline being created this
might be a specific stage being complete
we can actually use something like
Google Cloud functions or anything that
has an external endpoint and actually
write that into stackdriver using the
logging client library all right so what
we're able to do here is
you know we can configure echo and
spinnaker to basically write these
events to a Google Club function which
will then write that into stackdriver
logging so it's actually look at that we
can see here that I have a whole bunch
of different logs in sacral logging that
actually signifies some of these events
that Orca is emitting and what we can
actually do here and I haven't done this
in preparation for this but week
actually can create a log base metric
actually counts for something specific
it's like if a pipeline was successful
let's actually create a log space metric
based on a filter for that specific blog
right so this is something where now we
can then in metrics Explorer if we were
to create this create a dashboard that
provides that context of this deployment
happened and we're looking at all of
these let's say air response codes over
time right so again kind of marrying the
two concepts of automation
configurability definitely not an easy
task
but I do believe that there is a good
story if you're utilizing spinnaker to
integrate stackdriver within that to
implement the both of these pillars of
release engineering as the fine IDs are
ebook yeah so I think you showed us like
three really interesting things there
right the first one is just to include
stackdriver charts and your spinnaker
manual judgments opinion on that yeah
it's super useful because he actually
gives folks a sort of standardized way
to standardize ways to make those
judgments and then you showed us how to
actually do automation off those metrics
so have that pipeline make the decision
I'll have spinner can make the decision
based on those metrics and finally
actually use the data that's coming out
of spinnaker to inform you even better
to really understand how performance or
availability is impacted by deployment
events that's right all right cool so
let's review the three principles we've
covered today we started out by talking
about error budgets and SL O's and kind
of the big takeaway is there that one
like one you should use them they're
really good and two is that site driver
now with the announcement of anthos and
the aunt of service mesh this week
allows you to actually do proper SLO
monitoring so you should absolutely
configure SLO monitoring stackdriver
then we talked about observability and
how to use tag driver to collect the
golden signals from your services and
combine them into a single
place for analysis and then finally we
talked about actually including
stackdriver data as an input in your
release engineering practices
specifically how do you value we can add
canary judge using stock driver metrics
[Music]